I get frustrated when people don't show
up you know we don't can't just pick and
choose what we want to show Kyle first
of all how are you we are all
quarantined we are our own hair and
makeup people how does that go for a
real housewife because you guys love
glam you know I didn't expect to be a
hair makeup camera lighting and now an
IT person
I mean I've learned a lot about Zoom and
Skype and this has speedball promoting
it of the new season of The Real
Housewives nobody else that's kind of in
Christine how would the housewives do if
this cast was all quarantined together
non-stop for a month I mean I feel like
that happens on our trips I feel like
when we go on our terms it feels like
months actually um well some of us to do
okay together some of us would do great
and others not so well at all which is
what you'll see on this coming season
I'm really interested to see this season
because it feels like it's gonna feel
really different I mean what does not
having Lisa Vanderpump mean for the show
um well I just have every season always
has a different I say flavor for lack of
a better word there's so much going on
with each of these women in their lines
I mean every single person across the
board is so incredibly busy and so much
going on so that itself has so much
content and then the relationships and
you know all the stuff that happens
between the women it gets it's really
crazy I mean everybody's talking about
one relationship Denise Richards and
Brandi Glanville well yeah that
definitely came up she's not who she
pretends to be I don't deserve this that
is a huge thing to say
what could be that bad what can you tell
us well I think you're gonna have to
tune in and find out just like last year
right out of the gate the whole you know
puppy gate thing happened and this
season was no different something just
came up
and ended up obviously this show is
documenting what's going on in our lives
and the thing that you don't want talked
about the most is definitely gonna be
talked about this know that if you're on
a reality show so that's you know what
happens do you think Denise knew that I
think a lot of people are kind of naive
coming into this Denise's first season
she was asking where craft services was
and I was like honey this is a reality
show there's no crap service so yeah
it's definitely it's it's kind of
shocking when you first join the show
yeah you you are your own craft services
exactly
so did Denise change the last season one
to two like because she'd had that
experience and she knew what was up I
think that she which happens often with
second season housewife is what kind of
see what people didn't like when they
got them set about and they may kind of
like sort of try to censor themselves
and it just that's you know doesn't
always work so yeah I think Delta's like
oh you know maybe I went too far with
talking about that the happy end that's
what Kyle we I mean well do you think
she regrets sharing that I think perhaps
I think perhaps she does but regrets I
yeah you don't want to be here then go
don't try and destroy my family
what if she's manipulating me you sent a
cease-and-desist
who told you that you're so angry how
would you describe the season in one
word
I mean wild there are so many dramatic
things and a lot of conflict but we also
have a lot of fun otherwise I smoothies
sitting here ten years later talking
about the show right I couldn't do it if
I didn't have fun times and we really do
have a lot of fun and all the women even
that we fight and you know things come
up and people get upset
and then not talking which is even right
now you know they're all really great
women I have a lot of them so you know
I'm able to you know still have these
relationships and still have fun and
enjoy our trips yeah you know I all
right you can learn my lesson Kyle I'm
sipping the tea who's not talking right
now
Oh makes it my tea too well I don't
think I can say that exactly but I can't
either there sir here's the deal
a lot of us weren't talking and then
honestly um my partner with my clothing
line Shahidah my clothing line Kyle and
Shekinah she was able to get 8,000 mass
and 95 masks I reached out to the chaos
and a group text
um and I said listen would you like to
as a group donate 5,000 masks to Los
Angeles hospitals and they all
immediately replied yes yes yes and they
were really happy to donate these masks
to the hospitals here in LA as a group
and it felt really nice because you know
it sort of broke the ice while we're
doing a nice thing and coming together
so that felt good but with that said by
the reunion time nobody will be talking
right you you watch it and everything
comes back up I mean I guess I'll ask is
anyone on speaking terms with Denise
right now oh yeah okay yeah is anyone
not I think I would like to say that I
mean ya know there are definite people
that aren't speaking
I've watched the show for a long time I
love the fun of course we love the drama
you guys bring new and different stuff
each year but this season I think you
know again it's something we've never
seen before I mean we're getting
glimpses of Denise and her husband
seeming to walk away from filming there
are rumors that Denise quit during
filming and I don't think that's ever
happened in the show's history what can
you tell me about the reality of what
went down what happened last year yeah
it was really strange to me because you
know after a decade of doing the show
we've had so many things that have been
really difficult you know there's
nothing happened to my sister and me and
I mean the Taylor Armstrong went through
and then Camille everybody and nobody
ever walked away we just you know I
didn't even think that was an option
because we are here documenting our
lives and that's we signed up for so I
was a little taken aback you know just
like this is you know what you signed up
for and it works like it's hard and it's
not just all fun and going to parties I
get frustrated when people don't show up
just because that's what we signed up
for like I said there were so many times
I would have loved to not show up and so
many people that I would have loved to
not been around at the time but I ever
once done that in 10 years so it was a
little frustrating to me you know we
don't can't just pick and choose what we
want to show otherwise we wouldn't you
know be on the air still like we have to
or document in our lives the good the
bad and the ugly so you feel like Denise
was picking and choosing um I feel like
you know when they got hot in the
kitchen she left
does it get hot in the kitchen with her
and Brandi Glanville yeah well you don't
have to wait to see I mean this I'm
you're gonna have to watch the season
you're gonna have to watch the season
okay let me ask you when you started
hearing about the rumors whatever they
are
what's your own reaction um well it's
all right well I'm sipping the tea while
we're talking about the tea okay I mean
it could not be more appropriate right
now and I also see and I have really
been a little too much highlighter so
pardon my makeup no you honestly look
beautiful what
was my reaction I mean I was taken aback
not that it's so I mean take to each his
own but just like you know obviously May
first here something like that I mean
and someone's a married woman it's like
salacious and oh my gosh but you know
it's also someone's life and it's like
oh god like once something's put out
there it's out there and then the I know
what it feels like to have something you
know out there in about yourself or your
family whatever and it's painful and
it's difficult so obviously I was
thinking about that I think what is
surprised me about these rumors though
is that in her first season Denise
seemed pretty open she talked about
bringing air into a massage parlor to
get him a happy ending she talked about
Charlie Sheen her ex bringing
prostitutes to Thanksgiving dinner she
didn't seem to be holding back so that's
what has surprised me that's what
surprised me as well actually I was
thinking okay you know I wouldn't think
that she would have reacted like that
and had it be that big of a deal
considering how she's spoken in the past
and that sort of kind of was everybody's
reaction honestly so um but you just
never know you know when it's not on
your terms and sometimes I don't know I
don't know I feel bad to speak for her
but I can't a it was it was really wild
it was it was a that's why I use the the
royalties so do you see Denise coming
back and filming again I don't know I
don't know I don't know I mean I would
like to think yes you know I mean I
never had an issue with her before any
of this came up and I would love to see
her continue to be a part of the show no
but that said not everybody can handle
it
will she be at the Reunion anyway to
Skype your resume right now and to ask
her
well Kyle we love that you are still
part of the show um the Housewives
franchise is now getting into a place
where some of the OGS are you know
leaving I mean Vicki Gunvalson just left
we've had oh geez leave and come back in
the past like Bethenny Frankel but she's
just left again are you gonna ride this
thing and until the end I mean I always
just say that you know when the bad
outweighs the good I just when I will
I guess hang up my diamond this I guess
I would say but you know until it's not
fun anymore I guess I'm still here all
right well I have a real rapid zoom
round for you you think Brandi and Kim
should be full housewives again I mean I
know people love to see them on the show
so is that a yes I think that would be
great I do I think that was my dog
growling by the way I think that they're
a great addition to the show so why not
you know who causes the most trouble
this season well Brandi talked about
definitely uh sparked a lot
teddie certainly doesn't hold back and
you know bringing up things who makes
the most enemies well I'm gonna have to
say I mean up god I'm gonna have to go
with Deniz just because her you know
kind of walking off and not wanting to
participate didn't really sit well with
the rest of us who show up everyday so
she just who kind of walked away from
filming more do you think Denise or Lisa
like Denise come back at versus Lisa was
totally dying to how are they yeah then
I would have to go with Lisa
I mean Denise has shown up as you I've
seen in like a promo or something really
a green screen yes exactly that part so
she came back at least we know was doing
her interviews and talking so yeah
[Music]